[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel plaisir de vous voir tous
rassemblés et permettez moi de commencer
en remerciant luc chatel et bernard
accoyer et tous ceux qui ont organisé ce
conseil national
comme tous ceux qui se sont exprimés
avant moi et qui ont affirmé notre
volonté d'unité de rassemblement pour
remettre la france en marche
c'est un bonheur pour moi ce matin de me
retrouver dans ma famille au milieu des
république candidat à la présidence de
la république
je ne suis plus l'homme d'un parti mais
je n'oublie pas d'où je viens et surtout
je ne vous oublie pas je sais que vous
serez en première ligne je sais que
c'est sur le terrain avec les cadrer
avec les militants des républicains que
la victoire aux présidentielles et aux
élections législatives va nous permettre
de gagner pour redresser notre pays
je suis fier de notre parti je suis fier
de notre parti qui a su démontrer aux
français sa capacité à organiser une
primaire vraiment démocratique et je
veux remercier toutes celles et tous
ceux qui en ont été les artisans et au
premier rang d'entre eux thierry solère
notre primaire a été digne elle a été
digne de vous elle a été digne des
militants elle a été digne de nos
concitoyens qui attendent le meilleur de
leurs responsables politiques
certes la compétition était là mais il y
avait du respect il y avait de l'estimé
entre nous tous et je veux à ce moment
saluer notre ancien président nicolas
sarkozy
le remercier pour son soutien et pour ce
qu'il a fait pour notre parti saluer et
remercier alain juppé bruno le maire
nathalie kosciusko morizet jean frédéric
poisson et jean françois copé j'ai
emporter la partie le score a été franc
et sans appel
mais personne n'a perdu parce qu'au-delà
de nos personnes c'est notre démocratie
qui a été victorieuse et c'est une
nouvelle image de la droite qui s'est
imposée aux yeux des français avec 4
millions d'électeurs on a mis la barre
très haut
alors on va voir si le parti socialiste
jamais avare de leçon démocratique est
toujours prompt à se présenter en partie
du peuple est capable de faire aussi
bien
quant au front national pas de primaire
la démocratie y est remplacé par la
généalogie et les querelles familiales
après ma victoire je me suis attelé au
rassemblement de toutes les forces et de
toutes les sensibilités de ma famille
politique j'ai tendu la main à tout le
monde et tout le monde l'a saisie vous
allez être les fers de lance de ma
campagne
j'aurai besoin de chacune et de chacun
d'entre vous alors pas de calcul
pas de dispersion pas d'ego je n'ai
qu'un mot d'ordre unité et engagement
total pour la victoire
les faits
[Applaudissements]
l'essai
laissez les scénarios scénariste laisser
les sondages aux sondeurs ne nous
laissons ni enivré par les bonnes
nouvelles
ni abattre par les moins bonnes une
campagne présidentielle ça réclame
d'abord du sang froid et de l'ardeur et
la victoire viendra récompenser le camp
qui aura montré la plus grande
détermination
alors ne céder à aucune intimidation
on vous accuse de vouloir redresser la
france avec énergie assumer et riposter
parce que c'est nous qui avons raison de
penser que la situation réclame du
courage on nous accuse de défendre les
valeurs françaises assumer et riposter
parce que nous n'avons pas à nous
excuser d'être patriote d'être de droite
et d'avoir du bon sens
[Applaudissements]
je ne vais pas changer ce que je crois
est ce que je veux en fonction des
vapeurs des uns et des injonctions du
microcosme il ya deux mois je n'étais
pas son candidat favori
eh bien je n'ai pas l'intention de le
devenir ce n'est pas ça n'est pas de
l'obstination c'est tout simplement que
j'ai mes convictions et que j'ai la
certitude que mon projet peut redresser
notre pays
alors ce projet je vais l'expliquer je
vais le préciser
je vais l'enrichir de vos meilleures
idées mais pas de zig zag pas de
camomille
je m'appelle françois fillon pas
françois hollande
[Applaudissements]
pour moi la démocratie ça n'est pas des
convictions pour les primaires d'autres
convictions pour la présidentielle et
pourquoi pas d'autres convictions enfin
pour les législatives avec 6 millions de
français à pôle emploi avec cette
croissance maigrelette qui ne stoppera
pas la précarisation du pays
avec 2200 milliards de dettes avec les
extrémistes qui fondent vers le pouvoir
avec l'europe qui se traîne et face à la
menace du totalitarisme islamique
moi je ne vois pas l'élection de 2017
comme celle d'une alternance classique
non elle doit être le point de départ
d'un peuple qui par tous ses instincts
de vie se met à l'offensive et se met à
l'action nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
que d'aller à fond nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix que d'oser le maximum mes
adversaires pensent que les français
n'aspire qu'à conserver le peu qu'ils
ont c'est la théorie du partage des
miettes
je pense le contraire je pense que les
français sont prêts à s'engager pour
plus qu'ils n'ont et en cela mon projet
pour eux l'opportunité de secouer ce
système qui les brides et qui les
appauvrit avec vous je me bats pour
redresser notre pays et pour lui donner
un avenir pas pour ruser avec lui et
pour passer entre les gouttes
je me bats pour le progrès économique et
social
le progrès c'est toujours une dispute
sur nous mêmes avec nos conservatisme
avec nos égoïsmes avec nos peurs
personne ne va nous faire de cadeaux ni
le nouveau président américain ni celui
de la chine n'aurez vous pas d'une
soudaine croissance internationale qui
viendrait nous tirer d'affaires de new
dépendent notre avenir et celui de nos
enfants
évidemment nous pourrions comme la
gauche mettre en sourdine la vérité
nous pourrions mettre l'intérêt national
de côté nous pourrions mettre de l'eau
dans notre vin mais ce serait de la
lâcheté et vous n'êtes pas lâche et ce
serait au surplus ne pas avoir compris
la colère qui gronde
les français en ont plus qu'assez des
demi mesures
quant à nos électeurs ceux qui forment
le coeur de la droite
ils veulent un cap ils veulent des choix
clairs ils veulent la liberté l'autorité
la fierté nationale
c'est leur message et c'est les miens
alors certes la force et la franchise de
mon projet m'expose au blâme et aux
caricatures de ceux qui sont en réalité
mou est flou les balles sifflent de
partout visiblement je gêne et on
cherche à nous intimider
lors de leur premier débat télévisé les
socialistes ont plus prononcé mon nom
que celui de la france
tous quatre filles ont tous contre la
droite touche contre ces pauvres
électeurs de la primaire qui nous
respectons à l'envi ne représente que 4
millions de français mais il ne suffit
pas d'être contre
encore faut-il avoir quelque chose à
dire quand il à dire quand il a proposé
aux français ce qu'ils nous mitraille
quand il à dire à ceux qui nous
caricature et qui n'aime la droite que
lorsqu'elle marche à l'ombre
rien de nouveau rien de sérieux pour
répondre à l'urgence d'un pays qui
décroche le déclin est là la colère
monte
mais ces gens là vous disent qu'il faut
rien changer contre le redressement
national mes adversaires ont rédigé leur
tract sang et larmes purge casse sociale
et pourquoi pas l'apocalypse
il m'arrive d'entendre certains à droite
utilisé les mêmes mots que la gauche que
ma victoire et pu décevoir certains jeux
puis le concevoir
mais j'attends de mon parti de la
responsabilité et de la discipline
[Applaudissements]
la casse sociale elle est là elle est
sous nos yeux la casse sociale elle
truffe le bilan de françois hollande et
ses anciens ministres qui nous donnent
aujourd'hui des leçons je vaincrai leurs
mensonges je vaincrai ceux qui
prétendraient enchanté la france en lui
jouant un air de pipeau la vérité la
raison le courage seront plus forts que
les tartarinades habituel quel que soit
le vainqueur de ces primaires
oui mes amis il y aura de toute façon
une immense différence entre nous moi je
veux relancer la france moi je veut
redresser notre pays
moi je veux lui rendre sa fierté à
gauche on veut juste l'assister dans son
déclin monsieur macro compris et madame
le pen aussi
[Applaudissements]
à cette capitulation j'oppose un chemin
plus grand plus droit un chemin exigeant
mais tellement plus engageants puisqu'il
s'agit de faire de la france une
puissance gagnante
la première puissance européenne d'ici
dix ans alors soyons passionnés nous
allons larguer les amarres et nous
allons nous détacher de cette chape de
plomb idéologie qui a piétiné l'amour de
la france qui a piétiné le goût du
travail qui a piétiné la récompense du
mérite qui a piétiné le change de
l'autorité qui a pris et signé ce qu'il
y a de plus lumineux en nous la liberté
g
j'ai appelé cela la révolution du bon
sens je regarde l'horizon proche et je
vois ce que la france pourrait être si
nous prenons fermement les choses en
main le pays de l'audace plutôt que
celui de la bureaucratie le pays de
l'emploi plutôt que celui des 3000 pages
du code du travail
le pays qui investit dans l'avenir
plutôt que d'étouffer sous la dette
le pays du dialogue social plutôt que
celui des diktats syndicaux
le pays de la solidarité et pas celui de
l'assistanat le pays les initiatives et
pas celui les circulaires d'une société
soumise où tout est nivelé où tout est
encadré où tout est figé au nom d'un
misérabilisme nous nous passerons à une
société d'engager et d'engagement avec
tous les français qui veulent réussir je
fonce pour une france du plein emploi
pour une france productive c'est ma
priorité absolue
il faut travailler touche pour produire
plus et pour gagner plus et il faut en
parallèle remettre nos finances
publiques en ordre
parce qu'il faut mettre un terme à ce
cercle vicieux toujours plus de dépenses
toujours plus de déficit est donc
toujours plus d'impôts est toujours plus
de charges
oui je mets seraient massivement les
charges qui pèsent sur le coût du
travail et sur la feuille de paie ce
sera ma priorité absolue et c'est ça ma
façon de répondre aux aspirations
populaires
[Musique]
je donnerai ou d'entreprises la liberté
de négocier le temps de travail avec
leurs salariés
je reverrai notre système éducatif
je généralise ray l'apprentissage jeu
refondre est la formation
professionnelle je développerai le
statut de l'auto entrepreneur
je créerai celui de prestataire
indépendant
je miserai à fond sur les technologies
nouvelles et j'aurais formeraient
l'assurance chômage
[Applaudissements]
jobs
je veux plus de confiance pour ceux qui
font tourner les moteurs de l'économie
française oui j'assume je préfère
valoriser les fortunes françaises qui
investissent en france plutôt que de
ramper devant les fortunes étrangères
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure politique sociale c'est
celle qui donne du boulot à ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas et c'est celle qui permet
à ceux qui en ont tant de progresser
dans leur carrière et dans leur salaire
je veux agir pour les jeunes qui se
cassent les dents sur la rigidité du
code du travail
je veux agir pour les chômeurs qui
préfère bosser le dimanche plutôt que de
pointer pôle emploi le lundi je veux
agir pour les ouvriers qui préfèrent
travailler un peu plus
plutôt que de ne plus travailler du tout
[Applaudissements]
les socialistes rené couvre les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées qu'ils
avaient supprimée par revanche
idéologique et certains d'entre vous se
demandent s'il ne faudrait parvenir à ce
dispositif
non et je m'en explique notre projet
repose sur l'allongement de la durée du
travail par la négociation par la
liberté donnée aux acteurs de terrain de
discuter et de décider par eux-mêmes et
pour eux mêmes
la durée du travail dans l'entreprise
elle se définit principalement par un
critère c'est le seuil de déclenchement
des heures supplémentaires si on
réintroduit la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires alors l'intérêt
de négocier un allongement de la durée
du travail disparaît pour les salariés
même pour les entreprises faudra mieux
rester aux 35 heures et bénéficier des
avantages fiscaux et sociaux dès la 36e
heure enfin cette mesure se heurte à une
logique évidente
la gauche a imposé les 35 heures et on
ya ajouté des baisses de charges qui
coûte aujourd'hui près de 20 milliards
d'euros à notre pays pour compenser la
perte de compétitivité des entreprises
franchement est ce qu'il est raisonnable
de dépenser massivement de l'argent
public pour réduire le temps de travail
et ensuite de dépenser massivement de
l'argent public pour l'augmenter non moi
je veux qu'on en finisse définitivement
avec les 35 heures je ne serai pas le
président de la république reculera
devant cet obstacle
est ce que les français en seront
récompensées évidemment parce que lorsqu
ils travailleront plus il ya un gros
plus qu'aujourd'hui pour réussir toute
négociation d'entreprise avec l'accord
majoritaire cherche un compromis gagnant
gagnant mes amis ce que je veux faire
d'autres pays l'ont fait il s'agit pas
de les copier mais il s'agit de méditer
le résultat il ya une dizaine d'années
l'allemagne avait un taux de chômage
supérieur au nôtre
depuis il a été divisé par deux grâce à
une réforme courageuse de son marché de
l'emploi
quatre millions d'emplois ont été créés
chez nos voisins quand le nombre d
emplois dans le secteur marchand chez
nous restait stable par sa productivité
retrouver l'allemagne voit sa caisse
d'assurance chômage dégager des
excédents record alors que notre unedic
aligne les déficits depuis dix ans
l'assurance-maladie allemande est elle
aussi en excédent alors que notre
sécurité sociale a enregistré 100
milliards d'euros de déficit
outre-rhin les salaires ont récemment
progressé de 4% en moyenne
chez nous c'est à peine mieux que la
stagnation alors mes amis ne vous
laissez pas abuser
ceux qui prétendent qu'en allemagne
c'est l'austérité et qui défendent notre
modèle économique et social avec des
trémolos dans la voix sur les mêmes qui
qualifie mon projet brutal mais ce qui
est brutale c'est leur échec c'est
l'échec actuel ça n'est pas mon projet
mon projet des responsables mon projet
il est efficace
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire il
et paraissait sioniste ou
déflationnistes
je n'envisage pas de faire baisser les
salaires je souhaite au contraire les
débloqués par le travail je ne milite
pas pour la fin de toute dépense
publique
je souhaite les ramener de 57% du pub à
49% 5 ans je ne met pas fin à
l'administration française et à ses cinq
millions 600 mille agents publics
je veux en réduire le nombre de 8 % sur
le quinquennat
je ne prétends pas revenir à l'équilibré
de nos comptes publics en 2018 mais en
je ne sais release pas l'investissement
puisque je veux au contraire le stimulée
par une fiscalité plus favorable et par
des privatisations que nous affecterons
aux grands projets technologiques
je n'oublie pas les français puisque je
propose 10 milliards de pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire pour les salariés à
travers la suppression de la cotisation
salariale maladie et à travers une
véritable politique familiale qui
retrouvera sa générosité et son ambition
je ne sous estime pas les efforts de mon
plan mais il est raisonnable et il est
totalement tourné vers l'amélioration de
la vie des français
la souffrance ne fait pas une politique
mais le renoncement pas davantage la
mécanique du déclin économique et social
de notre pays elle est connue la montée
sans fin des dépenses et des
prélèvements publics et 30 de la
production privée
dès lors ce sont les importations qui
répondent à la demande au détriment de
l'emploi le chômage de masse a fait
basculer des pans entiers de la
population et du territoire dans la
pauvreté
d'où la pression en faveur des trans
forces sociaux accrue qui sont financées
dans un premier temps par la dette mais
qui appelle inévitablement de nouveaux
impôts je veux casser cette spirale
infernale
je me la casse et non pas par
l'austérité la déflation mais par la
production et la reflation je vais
libérer l'activité de tous les secteurs
d'activité qui ont été bloqués par le
matraquage réglementaire et fiscal
l'agriculture l'industrie les services
la construction
oui nous allons effectuer une marche de
fonds pour améliorer tous les facteurs
de production du travail à l'innovation
en passant par le financement et
l'énergie nous libérons l'activité tout
en veillant non pas à la protections des
passes mais à celle des personnes
notamment par un effort d'éducation et
de formation tout au long de la vie et
cette restauration d'une production
française compétitive et bien elle
permettra de distribuer des richesses
créées au lieu d'égaliser la misère
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
le revenu moyen d'un français est
inférieur de près de 13% à celui d'un
allemand nos concitoyens sont étouffés
par la croissance molle par le chômage
et par les impôts eh bien nous allons de
nouveau les laisser respirer la liberté
je la mets là la france unie et
fraternelle telle que je la veux la
france unie attaché à une certaine idée
de la famille a été dédaignés
et bien moi je la protégerai moi je lui
redonnerait ses droits parce que la
famille
c'est l'un sinon le principal pilier de
notre société et sans la famille nous
n'avons aucune chance de retrouver
l'unité et la dynamique dont nous avons
besoin
[Applaudissements]
la france unie se joue à l'école de la
république
elle doit savoir transmettre les
fondamentaux autour desquels nous devons
concentrer les efforts plutôt que de
multiplier les activités périphériques
oui nous rendons aux collectivités
locales la liberté en ce qui concerne
les rythmes scolaires
[Applaudissements]
les sols
l'école qui doit préparer un métier avec
une valorisation massive de l'internât
l'école de la république
symbolisée par le port d'un uniforme
scolaire donnant à tous les élèves
quelles que soient leurs origines
le goon est en chambre tous égaux
rassemblés dans la république française
la france unis exigent l'autorité de
l'état
l'autorité de la loi la nécessité de
l'or mais il faut mettre des mots sur
les actes et je me rappellerai ce que
j'ai déjà dit puisqu'il faut bien que ce
qui se joue des lois l'entente de cinq
sur cinq
un délinquant n'est pas un mineur qui se
cherche
c'est un délinquance
[Applaudissements]
un criminel n'est pas une victime c'est
incrimine un jihadiste ce n'est pas un
déséquilibré c'est un terroriste
la sécurité doit être partout et pour
tous avec des forces de l'ordre
moderniser et une justice ferme et
rapide
l'impunité zéro doit être la règle je
veux rétablir les peines planchers pour
tous les récidivistes un délit une
sanction
voilà la règle qui doit être
parfaitement clair pour les délinquants
[Applaudissements]
la france unie n'est pas une addition de
communauté et de clans elle a une
identité
elle a des coutumes elle a une culture
elle un drapeau le repli communautariste
est un danger les 66 millions de
français ne doivent plus être encouragés
à dire et moi et moi et moi mais
entraîner à dire nous le patriotisme
c'est la seule façon de transcender nos
origines et nos religions
l'immigration
l'immigration sans intégration sans
assimilation doit être stoppée dans la
république française et étrangers ont
des devoirs avant de réclamer des droits
c'est une question c'est une question
d'unité nationale mais c'est aussi une
question de courtoisie car quand on
entre dans la maison d'autrui on y
impose pas sa loi
[Musique]
je veux je me réduire l'immigration un
strict minimum en l'organisant par
quotas en fonction de nos besoins
économiques et de nos capacités
d'intégration à ce que nous avons choisi
d'accueillir je veux plus vision avec
précision et fermeté ce que nous
exigeons d'eux exercer un travail
s'approprier notre langue respecter nos
règles communes
aux vrais réfugiés politiques l'honneur
commandes que la france tente sa main
mais avec les clandestins
elle doit être inflexible je veux te
mettions les états d'origine en face de
leurs responsabilités pour qu'ils
prennent leur part de la maîtrise des
flux migratoires et qu'ils s'impliquent
dans le retour de leurs ressortissants
oui je conditionnerait l'aide au
développement à leur coopération
[Applaudissements]
l'islam radical mine nos concitoyens
musulmans ils les un filtre et il les
prend en otage les fanatiques des tests
ce que nous sommes
je les combattre s en revanche et sans
pitié
je veux un strict contrôle administratif
de culte musulmans tant que son ancrage
dans la république ne sera pas
pleinement achevé
je veux la dissolution immédiate de tous
les mouvements qui se réclament du salat
fils ou des frères musulmans
je veux que comme la loi française nous
y autorise on retire leur nationalité à
ceux qui sont partis nous combattent en
syrie en irak où partout où ils
répondent à l'appel du djihad mes amis
autour de nous le monde est traversé de
menace et nous lance des défis
évidemment pour cela il faut un vrai
président de la république la fin de la
guerre froide puis le choc du 11
septembre ont provoqué une déflagration
du système international et un retour
fulgurant de l'histoire avec ses
rapports de force géopolitiques et ces
crispations identitaires
on ne répondra pas cette sursaut en se
repliant médiocrement d'ailleurs nos
frontières j'appelle de mes voeux une
france souveraine
appuyé par nos forces militaires dont
les moyens devront être sérieusement
augmenté
ma vision des relations internationales
est commandée par les intérêts de notre
pays et seulement par les intérêts de
notre pays quel que soit celui qui
dirige le kremlin à moscou
et quel que soit celui qui dirige la
maison blanche à washington
l'amitié n'a rien à faire quand on
défend la place de la france dans le
monde et la sécurité des français
[Applaudissements]
dans ce monde les dirigeants passent les
régimes évolué mais les nations
demeurent la france ni tiendra son rang
que par une politique d'indépendance
nationale
elle doit être libre libre de combattre
le totalitarisme islamique avec tous les
acteurs de la région sans aucune
exclusive
libre de dire non aux etats unis quand
ils imposent des sanctions monétaires
dans le monde libre de parler avec la
russie avec franchise la souveraineté
française ne peut pas être incarné par
un homme qui navigue à vue dans son
propre pays
avec françois hollande la france a payé
le prix fort pour apprendre qu'on
n'existe pas quand on ne sait pas ce
qu'on veut et quand on ne sait pas où
l'on va
dans ce 21e siècle qui bascule vers le
continent asiatique
l'europe doit constituer pour la france
un amplificateur de souveraineté je ne
parle pas du projet de fédération
d'états auquel je n'ai jamais cru ni de
l'europe communautaire et ses normes
byzantine je parle de l'europe des
nations unies pour défendre la
civilisation européenne et leur avenir
commun je parle d'une europe politique
concentrer sur cette priorité
stratégique jeux valve d'une europe
appuyé sur le haut qui peut devenir un
atout
entre les mains d'un gouvernement
économique européen je parle d'une
europe de la sécurité partagée dans
laquelle chaque état y compris
l'allemagne devra prendre sa part du
fardeau de l'effort militaire et de la
défense
[Applaudissements]
cette europe il faut la construire
demain et il parlait d'une voix claire
voilà mes amis le sens de mon projet et
voilà l'ambition française qui doit
dicter notre unité et nos efforts
l'ampleur et l'urgence du redressement
national nous commandera d'agir fort et
vite
avec pour première priorité l'emploi et
la croissance nous devons entendre les
français
nous devons entendre leur demandes
d'honnêteté de courage et de vérité face
aux conservateurs de tous poils nous
devons aussi faire le choix de la
modernité
la société change à la vitesse de
l'électron nos enfants m'ont plus vite
que nous
l'autorité du sommet sur la base ne
suffit plus à organiser une société où
les individus cherchent à décider pour
eux-mêmes et par eux mêmes je reviens
avec beaucoup d'entre vous des états
unis où j'ai vu cette modernité en
marche
les entreprises françaises sont prêtes à
relever les défis du monde nouveau pour
peu qu'on leur met pas de bâtons dans
les roues ou des taxes sur les robots
comme le propose un socialiste certes
jeu
mais bien ancrée dans le monde d'hier
[Applaudissements]
à nous d'en entendre aussi les demandes
de cette société qui réclament du
partage à nous d'entendre à tous les
niveaux et pas seulement en tant que
conseillère municipale la volonté des
femmes de s'investir dans la vie
publique
[Applaudissements]
nos investiture législatives sont en
cours et en matière de parité on part de
loin
c'est vrai que nous aurons du mal à
parvenir aux 50% mais mes amis je
n'accepte pas que nous nous donnions une
image vieillotte et misogyne la parité
n'est pas une contrainte c'est une
condition indispensable de l'unité
nationale et je vous le dis je veillerai
à ce que dans les semaines qui viennent
le nombre de femmes investies au
législatif soit en augmentation
significative
[Applaudissements]
entendent aussi les français quand ils
réclament des élus efficace et
disponible entendons leurs
interrogations et parfois leur colère
face à une démocratie qu'ils jugent
lointaine est privilégiée l'exercice des
mandats en 2017 n'obéit plus aux mêmes
règles qu'au début de la vème république
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
reviendrai pas sur la loi sur le cumul
des mandats
[Applaudissements]
comment
comment nos concitoyens pourrait-il
comprendre que nous nous occupions
d'abord de nous mêmes au lieu de nous
occuper d'eux je vous le dis aujourd'hui
avec franchise ce serait un bien mauvais
début de mandat pour moi comme pour tous
les parlementaires de notre majorité
alors maintenant nous avons quatre mois
laventure va mobiliser 100 % de notre
énergie
il va falloir tracé à travers les doutes
à travers les vents contraires à travers
les attaques à travers le conservatisme
d'un pays qui est en train de
s'organiser pour essayer d'empêcher
l'empêcher
l'impensable qu'il y ait enfin à la tête
de l'état un chef du gouvernement un
président de la république une majorité
parlementaire qui soit vraiment décidé à
changer les choses pour le bien des
français pour le plein emploi pour la
puissance française pour la liberté
et pendant ce national je vous entraîne
dans une bataille france dans une
bataille sans artifice dans une bataille
pour l'intérêt national
mais mes amis c'est la bataille gagnant
pour ceux qui aiment la france et y aime
les français vive la france vive la
république
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]